c'est une situation incroyable ça s'est
passé à l'ambassade comme un déclic de
quelqu'un qui fait dans l'assistance oui
l'ambassade rencontre entre le la
réception faite par l'ambassadeur avec
les milieux d'affaires avec lesquels on
était en contact et un homme après avoir
monté la normandie ce toujours des
aspects qui vient me voir et me dit
voilà je cherche désespérément des
vaches pour fournir le monde abattoirs
sur le coup je pour tout vous dire je me
suis dit mon anglais doit être si
mauvaise je le prends parce qu'ils me
racontent et ggv répétées et j'ai bien
compris il cherchait en effet un premier
un premier cargo de vache pour faire un
essai avec éventuellement la possibilité
d'en faire d'autres
il va les transporter en avion oui oui à
réparer que ça se fait on m'a dit
l'ambassadeur
alors immédiatement ce qu'on a fait
c'est c'est julie j'ai appelé le
directeur de l' agence de développement
qui étaient là j'ai appris mon directeur
de cabinet à quand je dis vous mettez en
contact avec les milieux agricoles
vous montez ça et nous on invitons
normandie véracité ça et sérieux l'homme
a pignon sur rue il existe c'est
vraiment un homme d'affaires bon
maintenant voyons concrètement si cette
histoire qui pourrait en effet de
boucher ce qui serait plutôt une très
bonne nouvelle pour la normandie